uh hi there steve kaufman
today i want to talk a little bit about
um
the details of languages
and um the reason this uh comes up is
because of the discussion we had
when i put up my video on uh learning
japanese and i used as an example
of japanese word order or structure the
sentence
so i use the word watashi for
i
and that generated a fair amount of
response
amongst
my viewers
from what i could tell they were all
non-native speakers
some had never heard the word watashi
before
and
someone suggested that the use of
watakshi was not appropriate and of
course capitalize them not
so it was very not appropriate
and this was very interesting because um
you know i have uh lived in japan or
i've lived in japan lived there for nine
years i've spoken japanese since
uh 1971
and i think mostly i if i'm speaking
formally i say watashi
um for whatever reason
uh probably if i'm speaking more
informally i might say watashi or more
often than not if i'm speaking with
friends i say boku because there are in
fact
a variety of ways of saying i in
japanese
the interesting thing in this is is uh
first of all i then went to my
forum at link and asked some of our
native speakers there and i got some
very interesting replies
and essentially the reply was that uh
watashi is by far the most common form
used in japan
but that it's not inappropriate to use
watashi which is a little more formal
than watashi but it's not very common
and you can get into more detail they
quoted various sources and so forth if
you want to go to our japanese language
blog or at least forum over at link you
can go and have a look in more detail
what interested me in this was that here
was a very small detail of the japanese
language
one that in 40 years no japanese person
friend business contact whatever and i
have spoken a lot of japanese no one has
ever commented on and generally the
reaction on our japanese language forum
was that there was not much there was
nothing much wrong in using watakshi but
it is less common
however people who have been studying
japanese have been taught certain rules
and so whether or not these people are
able to communicate in japanese whether
they understand a lot of japanese or not
i don't know
uh immediately they tune in on the fact
that this rule that they were given this
is how the language is somehow here i
didn't follow that uh convention
and so this became a bit of a fuss
my view is that in language learning
there are sort of there is the forest
and the trees
there are the details the nuts and bolts
and then there is the big picture
in my opinion successful language
learning depends on seeing the forest
the big picture and not being overly
preoccupied with the
details
uh it's not just that what actually in
japanese
even things like i don't know ser and
estar in spanish
which sometimes are difficult to get the
hang of you're not entirely confident
when do you ser the star despite having
read the explanations umpteen times
um this doesn't prevent comprehension
doesn't prevent you from understanding
doesn't prevent you from communicating
similarly with the subjunctive in some
of the romance languages
some of them some of the cases were used
as subjunctive or obvious some are less
obvious
but it doesn't prevent you from
communicating i know that in the
canadian
public service
where
people get a
bilingual bonus for being bilingual
um
english speakers native speakers of
english are tested on the french to see
if they qualify for this bilingual bonus
and they're marked down for getting the
subjunctive wrong
um
which to me is is absolutely ridiculous
the issue should be if that public
servant sits in a meeting
and everyone speaking in french does he
or she understand
can that public servant express an
opinion and get their views across in
french
and i can assure you that it's possible
to do both those things without being
right all the time on the subjunctive
it's also true
that in language a lot of this detail we
get it right sometimes and wrong
sometimes we might get it wrong and get
it right the next time or get it right
one time and get it wrong the next time
so that constantly looking for
where people have their shirt tail
hanging out
to me is not very uh constructive like
i'm i personally don't care in japanese
i will continue to say watashi
uh
it hasn't offended anyone so far in 40
years any native speaker so it to me
it's not a big deal
part of it is that the way languages are
taught very often the details are put up
front you know this again i had the
discussion somewhere but someone said
well japan japanese is an svo or an sov
language
um
a subject verb object subject object
verb like i never think of a language in
those terms i don't find it helpful all
i want to know is how do they say this
in their language uh and
you know you will soon discover in
japanese that the verb ends up at the
end a lot of the time or sometimes
there's only a verb or sometimes there's
no subject
you know there's a whole lot of
situations
that you have to get used to so being
thrown this sov svo at the beginning to
me doesn't enlighten the learner at all
it just makes them feel that there's a
lot of special rules and technical stuff
that they have to get into in order to
speak the language which i don't think
is the case at all
i mentioned that you know i googled
japanese grammar
on the internet the first thing that
pops up as usual is wikipedia and i
quoted in my last video and i'll do it
again because it's so to my mind and
outrageous
the article begins with the japanese
language has it has a regular agglutin
of a glutamate verb morphology
in language typology it has many
features divergent from most european
languages
its phrases are exclusively head final
and compound sentences are exclusively
left branching
uh blah blah blah i mean all this kind
of stuff now granted the average person
starting in the japanese doesn't get hit
with that
but there are a lot of people who might
want to hit them with that and i think
that you first have to get the big
picture the sense of the language
increase your vocabulary how do they say
this in their language someone mentioned
on one of our forums that linked that
before
language teach and he quoted an article
which i don't have in front of me
uh he quoted an article that said that
prior to the 18th century language
languages were taught primarily through
translation in other words this is how
they say this in their language and then
the whole grammar movement took over the
nuts and bolts people uh took over and i
think that that's a disadvantage people
get totally hung up on the nuts and
bolts and end up having a very limited
vocabulary again this article
this person quoted
pointed out that
with the arrival of these vast computer
generated corpora all of a sudden
language experts have discovered that
you need a very very large vocabulary in
order to read meaningful texts in
another language well yeah
tell me about it you know i have quite a
large vocabulary in
russian but if i move on to dostoyevsky
there's going to be a lot of words that
i don't know because i've read more in
tolstoy and
dostoevsky has somewhat different
vocabulary my day-to-day interviews and
echo must be are not a problem so yeah
you need a lot of words it's all about
words it's not about the niceties of of
these of these details you know
i i you know again i've said before i'm
very forgiving of of people who speak
english
i do business with people from many
different countries
and germans are gonna say uh
you know since many years i've been
speaking english whereas we don't say
that we say four many years or a swedish
person will say uh you know it is uh it
is many people in china instead of there
are because these are things that just
come from their language and they
haven't been able to get rid of these
habits it doesn't really matter
uh you know unless you're uh unless
you're a you know a
legal translator or something and this
is the other thing too that makes
language learning different from say
engineering
or some of these other sciences if
you're an engineer and you're building a
bridge
you know you've got to have your details
down or that bridge is going to fall
down i mean that's a completely
different situation from learning a
language where really all you have to do
is communicate
and the a few mistakes here and there
are not going to impede communication
now that's not to say that you shouldn't
work on improving and i do
but the best time to study grammar and
i'm having a
final time now going back to my russian
grammar books
for the seventh eighth ninth time
reading the same rules
and every time it just seems that much
more meaningful and every time i'm able
to take that back to my listing and
reading
and identify some of those things
that were described in those grammar
rules but if you're hit with the nuts
and bolts up front or if you're overly
concerned about the nuts and bolts
overly concerned about the details it i
think will impede your learning of the
language get the big picture in and then
you can go back in later
and
clean up
some of the bits and pieces and if some
of them don't get cleaned up
like my watakshi
then so be it i've enjoyed 40 years of
very successful communication in
japanese and i'm quite sure that that's
not the only peculiarity that i have in
my japanese
but if i go forward and i want to
improve my japanese i am more interested
in increasing my vocabulary so that i
can read
japanese literature so that i can
express myself better than worrying
about the few
loose threads or shirt tails hanging out
that are to be found undoubtedly in all
of the languages that i speak
so thank you for listening and we look
forward to your comments bye for now